NARRATOR:
This is the Shark Tank,
where hopeful entrepreneurs
get a once-in-a-lifetime chance
to pitch the sharks
in hopes of
getting an investment
to start, grow,
or save their businesses.
[ all cheering ]
NARRATOR: The entrepreneurs
must convince a shark
to invest the full amount
they're asking for,
or they'll
walk away with nothing.
I had the clown community
criticize me.
I'm not joking.
You don't want to piss off
the clown community.
They're gonna squash me
like a bug.
This is one of the classic
situations in "Shark Tank"
where you come in thinking
that it's worth $1 million.
Don't ask a million bucks
for something
that hasn't made any money yet.
what, are you guys nuts?!
Sure,
w-we have a budding --
shut up!
whoa.
NARRATOR: If the sharks
hear a great idea...
All you got to do is draw
some horns on him, and he's set.
...They're ready to invest,
using their own money.
whoo!
NARRATOR: And they're willing
to fight each other
for a piece of the action.
I'll give you
the $125,000.
HERJAVEC:
You know what?
I'll give you the $125,000,
no royalty,
if you do the deal right now.
"Boom" goes
the dynamite!
3...
Wow.
...2...1...
NARRATOR:
Who are the sharks?
They're self-made millionaire
and billionaire investors
who are entrepreneurs
themselves.
Kevin O'Leary
is a venture capitalist
who turned a $10,000 loan
into a software business
worth $4.2 billion.
Barbara Corcoran went
from waiting tables in Manhattan
to building the city's
preeminent real-estate empire.
Robert Herjavec, the son
of an immigrant factory worker,
is now a technology mogul
who sold his
first internet companies
for over $350 million.
Lori Greiner, the queen of QVC,
holds over 100 patents and
has launched over 300 products,
grossing over a half a billion
dollars in retail sales.
And Mark Cuban, notorious
billionaire entrepreneur,
tech guru,
and the outspoken owner
of the NBA's Dallas mavericks.
PADAWER:
My name is Lauren Padawer,
I live in Cordova, Alaska,
and I'm the founder
of Alaska Glacial Mud Company.
Besides running my company,
I work as
a commercial salmon fisherman.
Being a salmon fisherman,
you have to love
being out on the water,
and you have to love
taking risks.
It's not so different
than being an entrepreneur
and being able
to stick your neck out there
to do something you love.
[ kettle whistling ]
Hi.
This is Lauren.
Starting a business in Alaska
is challenging
because we're so far
from everywhere else.
Getting to meetings or just
paying for a plane ticket
poses some real challenges.
Alaska Glacial Mud Company
is treading water.
I need an investment
from the sharks
to take my company
to the next level.
I want everyone everywhere
to experience a little bit of
the purity and beauty of Alaska.
Hello, sharks.
My name is Lauren Padawer.
I live in Cordova, Alaska,
where I am both the founder
and owner
of Alaska Glacial Mud Company.
I'm here today seeking $100,000
in exchange for 20%
of Alaska Glacial Mud Company.
As a commercial fisherman,
I know Alaska is already famous
for wild salmon,
but someday,
I'd like to see us famous
for a luxurious
and nutrient-rich
Alaska glacial mud.
The idea
for Alaska Glacial Mud Company
started
on a wilderness rafting trip
down the majestic copper river.
As soon as I stepped in,
my feet sank into buttery mud.
It was such a divine sensation,
I proceeded to cover my face
and body in the silky mud
at the most wild spa
in the world.
After washing it off,
my skin was soft and glowing.
I want to see this amazing mud
become an industry standard
in the spa market.
So, sharks, who wants
to get their fins dirty
and play in the mud with me?
GREINER: [ chuckling ]
Mm.
Are you the only one
that ever discovered
that this was the best mud
in the world?
There is no other Alaska glacial
mud products on the market.
Lauren, can we see it?
Absolutely.
For you.
Thank you.
There's a mixture here
of some of
the different products we carry.
Thank you.
Thank you,
Lauren.
Mr. Wonderful.
CORCORAN: Thank you.
Barbara.
Very nice of you.
Mark.
O'LEARY: Have you processed
this mud in any way?
It goes
through a refining process
to ensure quality control.
The mud is --
'cause I-I'm worried
that a big bear
would've taken a large dump
near where you were.
[ laughter ]
Oh, God.
It's the cleanest mud
in the world,
and it comes from
one of the most pristine
wild rivers in the world.
I would actually really like to
have Mr. Wonderful come up here
and give you a glacial facial.
Whoa!
Okay, then.
I just hope I'm not
being covered in bear poo.
[ laughs ]
Oh, God.
No,
this is very pure.
GREINER: How long
would you need to leave it?
In order to dry,
it would take
about 10 to 15 minutes.
Does it draw the impurities
up out of your skin?
Absolutely.
It contains
microfine clay particles
that absorb toxins
and exfoliate dead skin.
Somehow this looks like
the true you.
CUBAN: All you got to do
is draw some horns on him,
and he's set.
[ laughter ]
what other body parts
can be used with this stuff?
Top of his head.
[ laughter ]
CUBAN: The color of money.
the color of money.
O'LEARY:
It's very cooling.
I feel the toxins
leaving my body.
PADAWER: The copper river
where this comes from
is an incredibly pure
and wild place
as you all may know if you're
fans of copper river salmon.
How much are you selling today,
and how are you selling it?
Our sales to date
are $36,000 a year.
Ooh.
$36,000 a year.
Do you have a small shop,
Lauren, that you sell it in?
No,
I do not have a retail shop.
We wholesale it to spas.
In Alaska?
We wholesale it
all over the world.
Your real target
that you most want are the spas?
Yes,
I'm interested in the spas,
but there is a lot of products
on the market
that people buy
for themselves at home,
I mean, especially
in more depressed economies,
people who can't afford
to go to a spa.
What does that jar sell
for retail?
It sells for $34.
And what does it cost
to make one jar?
About $3.
CUBAN: That's good margins.
It's hard
to crack into the spa market
is the problem
because...
it's so hard.
...There's so few products
that spas carry.
It's so hard.
They'll usually
carry one product
and then
endorse the line.
So I understand why you're
having a problem getting in.
It's a really great concept,
but there's hundreds of people
that want to get in
but so few that ever can.
And for that reason,
I'm out.
It does take a lot to break
in this industry,
and I will --
yes.
How much money have you
put into it, Lauren?
I've put $50,000
into the business.
Where did you get
that money?
That's from money that
I have saved over the years.
Fishing is where
I do make my income.
The fishing is only three months
out of the year.
Scary, isn't it, when you put up
everything you have?
How much money do you make
on the fishing side?
I gross a little over
$100,000 a year.
Wow.
Well, good for you.
You bring in
$100,000 a year?
Yes.
That's incredible.
That's amazing.
I want to buy
into your fish business.
Do you fish alone?
I fish alone.
Wow!
Really?
You're a beast.
Congratulations.
I-I am a risk taker.
It's largely a man's world.
There are seven woman who
professionally commercial-fish
in the town that I'm in,
but this is something
that I really felt I could do,
and it was naive to think
that I could go into this
and build the business slowly
and organically.
I honestly --
Lauren,
one of the biggest challenges
is making the decision when
to grow something organically,
just grind it out,
or to spend a lot of money
and go big and then
create pull-through demand.
Mm-hmm.
You've got to connect
to something
that's already in place
so people can connect it to you.
You might
want to look at
changing it
to copper river glacial mud
or something to leverage it
because --
I think
it's a good idea.
But because there's a big leap
from where you are
to where I think
you need to be to be investable,
for those reasons,
I have to say that I'm out.
Alaska's hot right now.
Alaska tourists
spend over $300 million a year
in products
just in our price range.
HERJAVEC: So, Lauren, your mud
may actually be better,
but the consumer walking
into the spa doesn't know that.
That's why I'm here.
But --
I need your help.
I mean, I have been working
really hard to make this happen.
I mean --
oh, I hear you,
but you could spend millions
to educate a market.
You can't go global when
you're doing $36,000 a year.
I'm out.
Okay, thank you, Robert.
You've got a lot of good things
going for you.
Thank you, Barbara.
And you have
a great story.
I could see you hanging out
with the bears...
I am a very sweet person.
...On the sleds with the dogs
and by a beautiful river.
I want to make this happen.
I invest in a company
called nardo's,
exactly the same space
you're in,
about a year
and a half ago,
and I've learned a lot of things
about the cosmetic industry.
Here's the thing.
It's very hard
to be retail and spa.
You have to figure out
what your market is,
or you're gonna waste
a lot of money.
I wish you the best of luck,
but I'm out.
Okay, thank you, Barbara.
CUBAN: Well, Lauren,
you've got --
I have Mr. mud face left.
[ laughter ]
Kevin has never
looked better.
O'LEARY:
My other problem with it
that none of the other sharks
picked up on
but anybody can go pick up mud
out of the copper river.
Right! They're gonna go
up there and say,
"Get out of the way,
Lauren.
That's my mud pile."
they're gonna squash me
like a bug.
No, no.
[ laughter ]
they've already done that.
O'LEARY: Tell me
if this is not the truth.
You're taking
a successful business --
your fishing business --
and subsidizing so far
an unsuccessful one.
I have a saying.
Any business that after
three years is not profitable
is not a business.
it's a hobby.
Look, I can't go down the river
with you on this one
because I've got mud
on my face.
[ chuckles ]
[ laughs ]
Okay, okay, look, look, look.
Look, Lauren --
I have companies
from China and Japan --
I've looked for every possible
reason to -- to invest.
I'm out.
Thank you. Well, thank you all
for your time.
Thanks, Lauren.
Thank you.
Really appreciate it.
Ciao.
Good luck.
I'm amazed that
she goes out alone and fishes.
That is amazing.
I think
I didn't get a deal today
because my sales
just weren't strong enough,
but I'm gonna charge on
and build the brand regardless.
NARRATOR: Next into the tank
are entrepreneurs
with a clever way to hide an
unsightly, everyday necessity.
BARZMAN:
Hi, sharks.
My name
is Mike Barzman.
And I'm
Bryan O'Connell.
And we're co-founders
of invisiplug.
We're looking for $125,000
for 10% of our company.
So, how many of you guys
own one of these?
Just one of the basic,
ugly power strips
that's a complete eyesore,
right?
We've done something
a little different.
Introducing invisiplug.
Invisiplug is the first line
of surge protectors
designed to seamlessly blend in
to hardwood floors.
Now, it's available
in three colors --
light natural,
medium cherry, and dark oak,
so it covers a wide variety
of hardwood flooring.
We just
launched the product,
and the response
has been overwhelming.
So, let me ask you guys
a question.
Who wants to get
into the power business?
[ chuckles ]
BARZMAN: Bryan, show them what
everyone's been talking about.
Let me show you guys.
So, sharks,
we need your investments,
we need
your expertise...
Thank you,
Bryan, thank you.
...And we need
your relationships
to help us as
we take this product to market.
So, there are
some very big players
making extension cords
that already have distribution.
Sure.
What is to stop them
from simply dyeing theirs
and crushing you
like the extension-cord
cockroaches you are?
We have
a design patent
that we actually received
on the process,
so we're proprietary
with the wood-grain printing.
So it's the look of the product
that's protected.
Exactly, exactly.
Somebody could make one
that looks like it
using a different process,
and the whole patent thing
doesn't matter.
O'LEARY:
So this isn't protectable,
so then it goes back
to my original question.
The guys that own this space
that make hundreds of millions
of these things
around the world,
what's to stop them
from absolutely decimating
this business if it ever
takes off in the first place?
Well --
CUBAN: Because it's niche.
There's no reason for them to.
You mean it's never gonna be
a big business?
Exactly, but the --
it's not gonna be exciting
to invest in.
question -- what are --
what are do you sell these for?
I'll never make any money.
is that what you're saying?
Our retail price is $14.99.
I didn't know
if you were gonna go --
try to go high end so that
if you worked with designers
and this was $249
because it was the only way
to get the perfect look
on your floor,
then I can see it, right?
If it's a $14.99 product,
it's gonna be perceived
as being inexpensive.
It's not really gonna
be perceived as a
solution in my mind.
I don't think
it's a real business.
I'm out.
I like the idea
that it's a $14.99 product
and anybody could afford it,
but might I ask you,
what do you pay
for a standard white one?
$6 to $12.
HERJAVEC: Bryan, how long
have you been selling it?
6 1/2 weeks.
The total amount
of units sold
is just under 1,500 units
as of right now.
What's the total sales
for that?
The total gross sales
is over $10,000,
and the total net
is just about $6,000.
We're doing
a special design two pack,
an exclusive product
for costco right now.
They give us a purchase order
for around 3,000 units.
If they do $500
of gross sales per week,
they will order a starting order
of 120,000 two packs
with a margin
that's about 78%.
So, I'm a computer guy.
I buy a lot of these.
I'm not sure
I see the market for it.
I think most people
that buy these things
put them behind a desk if
they don't like the look of them
to try to hide them somewhere
'cause even with yours,
even though
it's better-looking...
O'CONNELL: Mm-hmm.
...I still see the cord.
I still see the thing
on the floor.
It blends in better,
but it's still not
aesthetically pleasing to me.
For that reason, I'm out.
So, we have to pay you
$1.25 million valuation.
I think
you're gonna sell some maybe,
and if you do, good for you, but
it's not an investable business.
And the price you've asked
in terms of the value is --
is beyond insane.
Well, and I --
this is one of the classic
situations in "Shark Tank"
where you come in thinking
because you've lived
too close to it
that it's worth
a million dollars -- $1 million.
Don't ask a million bucks
for something
that hasn't made any money yet.
Sure.
What, are you guys nuts?!
Come on!
Sure. Out of all respect,
we have -- we have a budding
business that we believe --
don't give him
any respect yet.
and we respect your criticism
and your success,
and we have -- there's not --
and I appreciate your --
your thoughts.
Listen, on this planet,
it's not worth a million bucks.
On any other planet, it's not
worth a million bucks, okay?
Sure it is.
I'm out.
I'm the perfect customer
for this product
'cause my husband, Bill,
probably buys
six of these a week,
and I hate every one of them.
[ laughter ]
Okay.
He goes on a business trip.
I throw them out.
He comes home.
He buys new ones.
They're ugly.
That's hilarious.
All right, I would like to buy
at least three dozen from you.
That's fantastic.
But your [sighs] the number
you put on this business
Is nuts for a crapshoot.
Basically, it's a crapshoot.
I think you're gonna sell a lot,
but why
would I give you $125,000
for any percentage
to find out?
So, I wish you luck,
but I treasure my money
more than that.
I'm out.
Lori,
are there any questions?
[ chuckles ]
How much money
have you put into this?
We have around $70,000
into the company to date.
T-the real reason
we want the money
is because of the o mag article
that's coming out.
O as in
Oprah magazine?
Yeah. Yes, yes,
Oprah magazine.
Wow.
Oprah magazine
is featuring this.
As a new pro--
in their new-products section.
O'CONNELL: Yeah, yeah.
Okay, you will sell out.
I hope so.
God willing,
a-a-and that's
what we are kind of basing
a lot of our belief on,
you know,
with our product,
and the response
has been nothing but positive
from all these big-box people,
you know?
Impressive activity.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
I'm gonna make you an offer.
I'll give you the $125,000
for 10%,
but I want a dollar
per unit sold...
Until I make back my $125,000.
Mm-hmm.
And then I want 50 cents
forever thereafter.
Now, did you say
in perpetuity?
Yes.
Yes, yes.
CUBAN:
She said forever.
Yes, what it is,
is I want protection.
That's a Kevin deal.
O'LEARY: That's right.
That is a Kevin deal.
CORCORAN: No, if it's insulting,
it's a Kevin deal.
No, no, never.
Kevin never insults.
[ laughs ]
O'LEARY: You want protection.
You need surge protection.
Because I don't --
I need surge protection.
I need investment protection.
Absolutely.
Because you have a lot
of fish on the hook.
Thank you.
But I'm not sure.
You don't have proven sales.
Sure.
So it's as big a gamble for me
as it is for you.
So that's why I'm structuring
the deal this way.
Well, absolutely,
and you can understand
that for a company
in our infancy,
it's so hard to put
a real valuation on our company.
If we pull the trigger
on that costco order,
that's over a million dollars
in net profit,
and that's
just one order.
Tell me if this
is too much of a counter
along the lines
of 25 cents per unit
until you recoup
your investment
and then a possible 5-
or a 10-cent --
possibly, and I'd have to call
our advisor -- royalty.
So, here's going to be
my final offer.
$125,000.
I do want the dollar per unit
until I make back my $125,000,
but then I'll go to 25 cents
in perpetuity
off of each unit sold.
10% equity.
I understand it's a steep deal,
but it's what it will take
to get me in.
A-are you at all willing
to negotiate on the perpetuity?
I'm not.
Not at all?
You're nice guys, but it's what
I feel I need to make the deal.
Okay, guys, you got her to go
down from 50 cents in perpetuity
down to a quarter.
I don't think
it's an unreasonable offer,
to be honest with you...
no.
Sure, sure.
...Where you are today.
HERJAVEC: You know what?
The more you're talking...
Mm-hmm.
...The more impressed
I've been getting up here.
Oh, thank you.
Are you going to make an offer?
Coming back in?
NARRATOR:
Four sharks are out.
Mike and Bryan
have an offer from Lori,
but Robert may come back in.
HERJAVEC: You know what?
The more you're talking...
Mm-hmm.
...The more impressed
I've been getting up here.
O'CONNELL: Oh, thank you.
Are you going to make an offer?
Coming back in?
Yeah, I'll make you an offer.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you, sir.
I don't think
that the business
can afford the royalty
right now,
and I think you're willing
to give up a little more equity.
I'll give you the $125,000
for 25% straight in, no royalty,
and we're in this together.
"Boom"
goes the dynamite!
O'LEARY: Wow!
Hey, and I got to tell you,
you --
Robert,
thank you for that offer.
You convinced me.
Are you at all negotiable
on what you gave us?
Would you consider
coming down to 20%?
I'll do the 20%
if you do the deal right now.
Interesting.
$125,000, 20%.
Let's do it.
Can we still go back
and make a phone call?
Oh, man!
No.
What did I just say?
He just said
this was the deal right now.
What do you want
to do?
Um...
3...
2...
1...
[ murmurs ]
yeah.
We -- we'd like
to step back,
a-and we understand
that you're out.
[ all groaning ]
I'm out.
Whoa!
I think you're down
to one offer.
So,
to recap then,
you're offering $125,000
for 10%, plus...
Dollar per unit...
...Dollar per unit till --
...until I recover.
and then 25 cents...
And then 25 cents
per unit...
...In perpetuity.
Is there any room
on the royalty portion,
even, say, 5 cents
just to show a good faith
that you really believe
in what we're doing?
You'll walk away
with the 20 cents.
You'll get
the dollar back.
You'll have your equity.
And because of who you are
and your partnerships,
we would love
to take that deal,
and we think
that we could really do well
with you
in the future.
You guys, I really -- I respect
everything you've done,
but I did say that
that was my final offer.
Okay.
And so it is --
then we'd like
to take it.
Okay.
You've got a deal, Lori.
CUBAN: Congrats, guys.
Nice.
[ laughter ]
[ whistling ]
We're gonna sell
a lot of plugs.
It's a pleasure
to be in business.
I hope so. I hope so.
[ laughs ]
how about a hug?
[ laughter ]
thank you, Lori.
okay.
Cool.
We look forward to it.
CUBAN: Congrats, guys.
We'll talk soon.
CORCORAN: Ciao.
Good to see you guys.
Thank you so much.
We got Lori. Whoo!
That was great.
Well, you got yourself
a good deal.
That's a great deal
for you.
It's not even that bad for them.
And I'll support them totally.
It's not even that bad
for them.
Good business
is always good business.
We got
what we wanted.
It's awesome.
You know,
we gave up a little,
tiny bit more,
but we did it.
Yeah, that's really good.
[ laughs ]
NARRATOR: Last season,
Corey Ward and Trew Quackenbush
impressed the sharks and closed
a deal with Barbara Corcoran
for their grilled-cheese
restaurant franchise Tom+Chee.
I'd say
we take the deal.
HERJAVEC: Yes, sir!
All right.
Thank you, guys, so much.
Awesome.
Let's see
what they're up to now.
[ sizzling ]
Oh, it's a great-looking
sandwich, gentlemen.
Since being on "Shark Tank,"
our sales have been insane.
WARD:
Before "Shark Tank,"
it took us a year to reach
a million dollars in sales,
and in three months
since the show,
we've already
gone over a million dollars.
What can I
get you today?
WARD:
Before "Shark Tank,"
we only had 40 employees
in 3 locations.
Since the show's aired,
we're up to 80 employees
across six locations
and our corporate offices.
That's 100% job creation
in just 3 months.
Well, I want to welcome
everybody to the family.
Today,
we're closing deals
with our first three franchisees
since "Shark Tank."
we're gonna now have tom+chee
in New Jersey, Tennessee,
and Kentucky.
Hello, everybody.
ALL:
Hey, Barbara!
I'm so happy to be with you,
and I'm so excited
to meet your first franchisees.
Working with Barbara
has been great.
She's understood our business
model from the very beginning,
and she's made herself
available to us
whether it's through
e-mails, video chats.
She's there
to answer our questions,
and we do have
a lot of them.
I would like a Barbara blue,
please.
Just like we promised
on "Shark Tank,"
the shark
that invested in tom+chee
would get a sandwich
on the board,
and Barbara did,
so she got the Barbara blue --
smoked ham, Brie cheese,
blueberry compote
all on a yeast-glazed donut.
it's amazing.
[ laughs ]
Our "Shark Tank"
experience
has been a roller coaster
of emotion.
To think that we started
in a street tent
and now what the future
holds for us just blows us away.
ALL:
Thank you, "Shark Tank"!
[ all cheering ]
NARRATOR: Next up are two dads
who've created a product
designed to keep students
organized.
Hello, sharks.
I am Greg Cronin
from Clinton, Mississippi.
And I'm
Dr. Stephen Coachys.
I'm from
Ridgeland, Mississippi.
We are seeking $175,000
for a 10% stake in our company.
Sharks,
that is called disorganitis.
GREINER: [ chuckles ]
There are three symptoms --
lost homework, being late
for class, and falling grades.
But I have found the cure,
and it is lockerbones.
Sharks,
this is a simple product
that eliminates the mess,
reduces the stress.
Lockerbones is the best.
And remember,
an organized student
is a successful student.
So, sharks,
come one, come all,
but join us in improving
the organizational skills
of our future leaders with
the ninth wonder of the world...
BOTH: Lockerbones!
[ chuckles ]
It'll take just a moment,
But I'd like
to take this out,
put it right back,
and you'll see
exactly how it all happens.
that'll be helpful.
Yeah, yeah,
I'd like to see that.
All right.
COACHYS: Want you to know
as he's putting that together
that there are no tools that
are needed with this at all.
30 seconds --
it's in and out.
What does one cost?
Yeah,
but what does it cost?
[ laughing ] Yeah.
A single is $29.95,
and a double, which is normally
the 12-inch, is $39.95.
This might show you
the patented product.
Aren't kids gonna make that
in woodshop?
Not a chance.
[ laughter ]
no, you know what? there's
a lot of cuts in that, Mark.
COACHYS: Actually -- actually,
they might, but they can't.
There's a lot of precision
to this. [ chuckles ]
they can't make that,
Mark.
The reason is, is because
that has been patented.
Oh, so, you're gonna sue
a bunch of 7th graders.
How'd we get involved
in that?
No, we are gonna get 7th graders
to put that in their locker.
They're gonna have it,
no problem.
You know, honestly,
it's just easier to buy it.
Absolutely.
Once you take the two sides,
settle them in,
you take one piece,
and you put it
at any location you want
on that track system.
This becomes
the first vertical divider
in a locker because what happens
is, folders fall over.
They get on top
of each other.
You can't really
keep things standing up.
You slide it in.
You put it in place.
So, nobody else...
You now have vertical ability
to hold the shelves.
And here's a question.
Nobody else,
your competitors...
Right.
...Do not have
a vertical divider?
They do not.
And here comes your nook
and cranny.
You get two of these.
You can put them
anywhere you would like.
You can put reading books.
You can put
your cellphone.
Let me tell you
just briefly how this began.
About four years ago,
my daughter
was going to middle school.
It was
the night before
she needed her locker
organized the next morning.
I went out
to the garage,
took my table saw
out the back porch,
and I created
the first one.
I'm a contractor and
a developer, so I had the tools.
It was,
uh, you know,
rough around the edges
but very functional.
So, she woke up
the next morning, looked at it,
and goes, "Dad,
I'm not taking this to school."
Exactly.
CRONIN: But she knows me,
and we've done this many times.
Kids never appreciate
anything we do for them ever.
No.
Well, the telling sign was,
two girls walk behind us --
first day at a new school --
and they looked, and they said,
"Cool. where'd you get
that wooden one?"
We made
about eight or nine of them
for just close people she
had met that first little bit,
but then the school
organizational director,
the one who goes
and checks the lockers,
contacted me and said,
"This is -- this really works.
It's functional."
and he ordered 500 of them
on the spot.
We got 60 orders.
COACHYS: We have more parents
come to us and say,
"Why didn't we have that
when we were in school?"
how many parents
have you sold them to?
We've sold 500 units.
How long
have you been selling?
Two years
of this particular version.
We are here to request the money
to produce this in plastic.
What's your tooling gonna cost
to do this in plastic?
We paid approximately $28,000
to tool up
for the previous one
on a prior effort...
On a prior one.
It did not work.
...That failed.
You never got distribution.
GREINER: Wait, wait.
Let him -- let him talk.
This was --
this was a prototype, okay?
It's an entrepreneur's thing.
We failed.
That's fine.
CUBAN: Why did it fail?
Yeah, why?
We went in -- because it was --
it did not have
any of this track system.
What we've done is,
two years ago,
we came up
with this design.
We got the design patent
in early July of 2011.
Do you have a utility patent
or just a design?
This is
a design patent.
Just a design.
O'LEARY:
You've had it for four years.
Why isn't it ubiquitous
in distribution?
We've only -- no, we've only
had this for two years.
You've had this --
you've had this for two years,
and you've sold 500 units.
two years is a long time.
Right. This is
one school year last year
was when we introduced
this design, okay?
Did you go into the school
and show it?
We have 500 in this school,
which is 60% penetration.
I am so confused!
Me too. God.
Yeah, I want to --
just let me finish.
O'LEARY:
When you got in front of the --
we're all
still confused.
I want to hear where you're
in front of the Staples buyer
and you say, "Look at
this fantastic locker system,"
and he or she says...
what do they say?
Okay, Kevin...
Yes.
...We have been in front
of a major retailer, okay?
I'm getting excited.
That's one.
They loved the product
in plastic.
They loved
the function.
We have a contract
that has been negotiated,
put in place, okay,
for a 10,000-unit order
from the largest
online retailer
that will fulfill them
themselves
of this product
the way it is.
Right.
Okay?
Who is it?
It is Amazon.
Up to a million,
up to a million.
Okay? This is
for the wood version.
CRONIN:
That's for the wood version.
Now --
they're fine with that.
It is a contract that's been
exchanged but not executed.
O'LEARY: What? Why?!
We do not have the ability
to fulfill that 10,000
'cause we do not
have the capital
to put the inventory in place
at this time.
Okay, I got it. I'm interested.
They're waiting.
I got it, I got it, got it.
So, go to the next.
All right,
now next to retail.
Staples sells 30%
of school supplies.
We have not
approached them.
What?!
You never called them?
No.
W-- no!
Wait a minute.
No!
Wait, wait, wait.
Are you kidding?
Hold on. Let me --
wait a second.
I let this product stay
in one pilot school
on purpose
for one more year.
So, you didn't want to sell it.
So, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Now hold on.
You have it on Amazon!
You stopped selling.
COACHYS:
No, we don't have it there.
CORCORAN: What happened?
GREINER: Wait.
I have to execute you now.
I let this product stay
in one pilot school
on purpose
for one more year.
So, you didn't want to sell it.
So, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Now hold on.
You have it on Amazon!
You stopped selling.
COACHYS: No, we don't have it
there right now.
CORCORAN: What happened?
GREINER: Wait.
I have to execute you now.
A design patent
is not extremely strong.
Until you can go quick
and fast in this market --
they can buy one at Amazon
and knock it out.
You need to make it
out of plastic.
No, he doesn't.
And you need
to bring the price down.
Yes, he does.
Wood is too expensive.
CRONIN:
Yes, we do, and that's what --
he's got to change the color,
as well.
That's what Staples
and office depot want.
They --
how do you know that?
Office Depot
wants it.
How do you know that?
COACHYS: They --
you never called them.
And there's another
large retailer.
All they want
is it in plastic and color.
I really want
to nail this down...
Sure.
...Because this matters a lot.
Certainly, absolutely.
Amazon's going to buy
from you,
and they are saying,
"I am going to buy up front.
Here's a pledge."
how much?
10,000 units,
up to a million units.
We ship to them.
They warehouse it.
They sell it.
They have terms.
They pay us later.
This is not a P.O.
from a traditional retailer.
But, Greg, if they don't sell
it, you have to bring it back.
You do.
I got it.
It's a consignment offer.
It's a consignment offer, yeah,
very much.
All right, I love the proof
of concept, but let's be honest.
You're at the very beginning.
We are ready
to go to the world now.
No, I got it.
Correct.
I'm ready to go,
too.
COACHYS: Absolutely.
We want you to come with us.
[ laughter ]
I like to go on a trip.
Which world
are you all going to?
Why is the company
worth $1.75 million?
There are 98,000 schools
in the United States.
110,000.
Okay.
There are approximately
50 million school lockers.
Okay, so, your valuat--
if you take only .05%
of the market --
Greg, your valuation is based on
size of market. got it.
Size of market, .05% of 1%.
Not sure I like that answer,
but let me ask you a second
question -- my final question.
Where does my $175,000
get you to?
Does it get the product
into Staples?
Yes.
I'm gonna tell you yes,
and this is how.
One,
tooling gets done.
Okay.
Two, initial inventory is what
we'll be using the money for.
To fill purchase orders
or just to build inventory?
Well, he doesn't have
the orders.
He has to go out --
we're gonna go execute the order
we have on the table
with the confidence
we can fulfill it.
CUBAN: I'm gonna simplify it
here, guys.
Where you've killed it...
Is selling it in schools,
where it catches fire.
It's viral.
The kids love it.
But no discussion whatsoever
of selling it in the same manner
to the 110,000 schools.
All you have to do is go to the
middle school down the street
and wait for the orders and
then just go to one more school,
kill it again.
Go to one more school, not this
big consignment order to Amazon
where you could take
all your inventory.
It could all be sent back
if it doesn't sell through.
Respectfully -- respectfully,
we were not finished...
You know what, Mark?
There's nothing wrong
with what they did.
...With the response
to him,
and I know I didn't
give it quick enough
till we got an answer.
Yeah, no, I don't think
you're on the wrong track, Greg.
CUBAN: You're following
the dream, not the green,
so for that reason, I'm out.
HERJAVEC:
You know what? He is so wrong.
Robert and I don't agree
with that at all.
O'LEARY: Well, wait a second.
Wait a second.
Hear me on this -- New York,
Florida, Texas, California.
That's where
all the schools are, okay?
What you want to do
is sell 10% of the lockers
in those four states,
and you'll be filthy rich!
Great product,
but you didn't talk about
a distribution strategy
for just getting to the schools.
I'm out.
What I think you're doing here
is nuts!
I think you could get every kid
in every school
to be peddling for you,
and they're easy to recruit
'cause they're not looking
for a lot of money.
You're missing
the best opportunity.
I'm out.
Three sharks out,
two still in.
Let me -- let me tell you
where I'm at
'cause I-I think I've heard
enough to make a decision.
The idea of selling on Amazon
on consignment...
It's nuts!
Staples has 30% of the market.
To me, the path is very simple.
Get it to Staples.
I like the product.
It's probably the best product
I've seen for this application.
COACHYS: You will have to
buy one, Robert.
Hang on.
I don't want to do this deal
on my own, okay?
Okay. All right.
I think
Lori's interested in it.
Okay.
I'll give you $87,500 --
half the money
you're looking for -- for 25%.
Lori,
if she'd like to do it...
[ laughs ]
...It's up to her.
$87,500
for the other 25%.
Let me be clear before the other
people start making fun of it
'cause I'm the only guy who
made an offer and Lori maybe.
We are
at the beginning.
Right.
It's not like you guys came here
with $10,000 of real orders.
It's not like you came here
with a million-dollar company
and I'm trying to
take advantage of you for 50%.
It's a start-up.
There's four of us.
We each own 25%.
That's my offer.
I don't know where Lori is.
I like it.
I'm in with you.
Greg, there it is.
That's our offer.
What do you say?
So, what -- where are
your thoughts on the...
I-I think that --
I think that we can work --
with two sharks,
we got more.
We've got double
the contacts.
So, you're gonna be eaten alive
by these guys?
I don't think
we're gonna be eaten alive.
I think eventually,
we'll all eat together.
You got an offer.
What are you gonna do?
I agree.
We will accept the deal.
HERJAVEC: Thank you.
Lori, Robert,
let's do the deal.
Awesome.
All right.
Yeah,
nice job.
Good dad.
We're gonna straighten out
lockers in America.
Yeah,
thank you so much.
Lori,
appreciate it.
I think it's a huge problem,
and that's a great solution.
HERJAVEC:
It's a great product.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, guys.
Good luck, guys.
Congratulations.
Okay.
Well, it was a little bit more
than we wanted to give,
but we got a deal
with two sharks!
Boom!
Yay!
NARRATOR: Next into the tank
is an entrepreneur
with a way
to ease the difficulty
of dining out with kids.
Hello, sharks.
I'm Ben Alexander.
I'm from sunny Tampa, Florida.
And I'm asking you for $250,000
for 30% of my wild company.
Whoo!
Have you ever
gone to a restaurant
and you order your food
and there's nothing
the restaurant can do
to make the food
come out faster?
You might be impatient,
but you know how it is
when you have kids.
Oh, my gosh. They're swinging
from the chandeliers.
They're running under the table,
over the table.
It's crazy!
Well, that's why restaurants
turn to me
and my very unique,
very different,
very unexpected company
that uses creativity...
HERJAVEC: Oh, wow!
...To put balloons
in restaurants!
I am balloon distractions!
[ all cheering ]
Happy day!
Stop the madness!
[ laughter ]
We are the nation's
premier talent agency
for balloon artists
that we send
into national
brand restaurants.
We are the first company
to ever take this
and put this
all over the United States.
We made something special
for each of you.
Oh, wow!
GREINER: [ chuckles ] Yay.
Mr. Herjavec,
I know you love motorcycles.
I do.
So I made you
a very cool motorcycle.
Oh.
Oh, how cute!
Very cool!
Lori, I know that -- I know
that you are the absolute,
most awesome QVC shark.
You look
so much better now.
[ laughter ]
And -- and, Mr. Wonderful,
I actually made you
a Chiquita banana...
CORCORAN:
Oh, my God.
...Fruit hat.
Doesn't he look beautiful,
sharks?
Now, Barbara, you are the queen
of building sales organizations.
I've always wanted
to be a queen. Thank you.
[ laughter ]
You are.
And last but certainly
not least, Mr. Cuban...
Thank you.
...I'm a big fan
of the Mavericks,
and I made you a Dallas Mavs...
I like it.
...Basketball player.
I would love
for you to join me.
I will...
[ laughter ]
[ laughs ]
I'm an emotional guy.
Don't start crying yet!
Oh, my God.
You haven't even
started asking me.
Wait till
we say something.
I would love
to have you guys come in
and help me blow this up.
[ sighs ]
Thank you.
[ laughter ]
whoo!
Exhausting.
Oh, my God.
I-I need to ask
the most important question.
Yes.
Are you like this all the time?
I just wanted
to come out here
and share the joy that I have
in my heart about this.
I'm very worried you're going
to spontaneously combust.
[ laughter ]
No kidding.
Let's talk numbers,
or I'm taking out my penknife.
Okay, fair enough.
[ laughs ]
we do over $500,000 a year
in sales.
Okay.
I've done $4 million
since inception.
Wow.
What were your sales
last year, Ben?
The sales
were actually a little higher.
They were actually $650,000.
GREINER:
Wow, big drop.
So, why are sales
going down?
I recruited a lot of magicians
when the economy was really slow
and they were hurting.
And then the economy got faster,
and they started
getting more bookings.
I couldn't find people
to run regions,
and then what happened --
I had the clown community
criticize me online.
The clown community?
I'm not joking.
Those nasty clowns!
[ laughter ]
like, what --
what were they saying?
Oh, just, like, "Your business
model, it's terrible."
I'm the Sam Walton
of balloons.
You don't want to piss off
the clown community!
[ laughs ]
What business are you in?
You haven't
really told us.
Okay, restaurants pay us a fee
to have a balloon artist come in
and do balloons after --
distract the guests
on a regular basis.
You're a booking agency.
Yes, we are.
Okay,
so you book "talent."
Mm-hmm.
And they go out
to restaurants.
Yes. Let me explain
so you understand.
I really want
to build something
so that I can find
regional partners.
I've been putting out ads
and spending money,
and I have regional partners
who get started and go to this
and --
and don't pull the trigger.
I say to the regional partner,
"I'm gonna give you a percentage
"of the revenue
from the restaurants.
"you have to train people.
"they already know
the balloons
'cause you have to know
the basics."
As a matter of fact,
I go out and do balloons
in restaurants myself.
Oh, no, Ben, you got to focus.
You got to focus.
Okay.
Tell us the structure.
The regional partner sells
restaurants, trains people,
and watches
the schedule weekly,
so they're really
like a regional manager.
And how much
do you charge the restaurant?
I charge $40 to $60 a night.
What does the balloon artist
charge the kids per balloon?
Can I have her
answer this question?
She's a real balloon artist.
Sure, okay.
This is Josanna.
What we do is,
we have a tip button
that says we twist for tips,
and what we do
as a "subtle hint" is,
we stick a $5 bill in there.
So, what are you gonna use
the money for?
ALEXANDER: Okay.
It doesn't really sound like
you need the cash.
I want to franchise.
I do, because I want
to franchise this idea.
Oh, man,
you're gonna drive me crazy.
HERJAVEC:
You don't need a franchise.
You need
to build an infrastructure.
You need people
to manage.
I need a strategic partner who
can give me a little guidance.
If you think
that franchising is a bad idea
and you're an investor --
it's a real bad idea.
I'm teachable, guys. If this
is a sales organization --
but you're asking me
to give you $250,000,
and you don't have a plan
for world domination
of balloon twisters.
If I don't franchise,
I want to bring on
a full-time recruiter...
Right.
...Who understands this.
That's what I need.
Ding, ding,
ding, ding!
Operations and recruiting.
I can sell
20 restaurants a day.
You -- every region I visited
this summer, 17,000 --
okay, Ben,
Ben, Ben --
Ben, you -- you got to --
you know what?
You're a great salesman,
but you didn't show me
how I can give you $250,000
and get a great return.
I'm out.
Okay.
Miss Corcoran...
CORCORAN: Yes?
...You've built
sales organizations.
You want to know
what this is?
This is exactly like
building a real-estate business
with multiple offices --
no different.
Yeah.
So I really understand
your business.
I know you do.
Your whole organization
is reliant
on the right salesperson
in each region.
That's the key
to this business.
It's not
your ability to sell.
It's your ability
to recruit salespeople.
You've not succeeded
in doing that,
and that's
an Achilles' heel.
In your business,
that's gonna murder you.
[ sighs ]
You're a phenomenal salesman.
But you're not
a sales manager.
I would be so scared putting
my money in your business.
I'm sorry.
I'm out.
GREINER: I'm gonna tell you
what I think.
It is
an adorable idea,
but I have sales reps
that work under me,
and one
of the most important things is,
is that they're very focused
and organized.
And here,
I had so much trouble
understanding the business plan
and model
that I think it would be
very difficult for me
to invest
and give you my money.
I understand.
So for that reason,
I'm out.
Okay.
Mr. Cuban?
Your -- your business
is structured wrong,
but that's
the bad news.
The good news is,
if you get it together
and you get your sales
up over a million dollars,
this is an easily
sellable business...
yes.
...Particularly someone who's
already got offices in place.
We have fixed costs.
And you could sell it
for millions.
If we can get this to one --
shut up!
Whoa.
My suggestion is,
instead of
using regional managers
and regional partners
on a commission basis,
you go find the best
recent college graduate
management talent
that you can find.
Put them on a salary.
I got you.
Yeah, put them on a salary.
It doesn't have to be
a lot.
Give them some commission,
give them draw,
whatever it may be.
okay.
But develop
management talent.
You're not ready
for me yet.
I'd go crazy, and for
those two reasons, I'm out.
O'LEARY:
I like your business,
but you're missing the partner
that does the operations.
Had they been here
sitting beside you --
that ghost,
that clown, whatever it was --
I would've probably
done your -- your deal.
I like it
'cause it's so unique,
and I know how to sell this
business in a couple of years.
The riches are in the niches,
sharks, and you know what?
We already have --
we already have --
you got to listen!
O'LEARY: But the point is,
you -- you --
you can't get $250,000
from anybody in here,
not the way you're structured
right now.
Instead of leaving
with a heavy heart
and a crying clown,
you should say,
"I'm gonna take that advice
and run with it."
But today, I'm out.
Thank you very much, sharks.
CUBAN: Thank you.
Thank you for the balloon.
GREINER:
Thank you for our hats.
[ balloons popping ]
Oh, don't do that!
Oh, you're so mean!
Don't pop 'em!
Don't do that!
Kevin!
[ laughs ]
Oh!